thank you very much madam president first
of all i would really like to thank
the european parliament for raising
this important issue of access to the
number 08 100 thank you also for your
support for the measures proposed to be
carried out there until then for
market completion  unique digital
I would now like to answer a little
more in detail because the
question of Madame n'y a pas trois as the
goal of the nati was very clear but
also of Monsieur who links the
first thing wild coast
economic causes of these young people  who saves
like bruce from costco may be difficult
to establish s arises from keynote part
which two sons sajjad transit anncol
ended his son in control contours
and at the costes in national before it's going to
be a star mayence all he may be
exposed off-road the  man practices of the
citizen of the nationals had pioneer
legislation it is not for the beat it or
if you scholes from abroad know where
you are what we lived in order to giv  e
you i'm yours first to war and francis
deniau kadhafa reading is not communicated
and luck yes it says very clearly and
effective rubicam even if they are one
of the symbols nextiraone title n 6
beats codes introduced but i have to see
crossboard of  history chances between ford
and contributes to the two accomplices one
distinguishes mark is an example
major obstacle he draws under of action singh to the
maximum julian white voice termination
gates by delegate any act or 10 of
commission
i opt idof nexteer text or seven major
one side  the immense where they decrease or
time and risk of in christ or au costes
transit in interconnection cost for
short campaign parties contracting
from free phone number ones
edge also from fort lamy get out of sight
commission cause monitors
development also oued fodda action
unpublished jump
once again I really want to
thank the members of parliament for this
debate which is useful for us for
our follow-up work as I live  ns to
say we will continue to follow the
market the evolution of the situation in
this area in order to determine if
further measures are necessary in
the future
the message is the following we have
taken steps forward
we will see what is  the effect they will
produce but already thanks to this debate there
the millet we have also followed more
closely the trends the developments to be
able to act in time because after all
the technologies evolve extremely
empty quickly it is important for us
too  not to be late
thank you very much madam president and
thank you again to the members of parliament
who would see match madam commissioner of
the best by tina teng biao objections
agent